i've got
good morning good morning um i'm sorry
i'm a few minutes late i am trying to
get election law things taken care of
for the calendar along with every other
committee chair in this building
welcome to the new hampshire house
special committee on redistricting we
haven't met in a while we are here on
thursday the
14th
um at 10 o'clock to consider bills
relating to the senate and executive
council districts which we have received
from the senate senator gray is with us
but before we begin i ask that you all
rise and join me in a pledge of
allegiance
i pledge
allegiance of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
thank you very much and thank you
senator greg welcome
well thank you my name is james gray
i represent senate district 6 which
starts in rochester goes up route 11
into belknap county alton barn said
gilmanton
uh what you see in front of you
uh and it's easier described on the the
map that you have provided for the
people here
is the senate
redistricting plan
of note
uh things that happened is that with the
shift of population
the northern part of the state
decreasing population in the southern
portion of the state increasing
population
and
that population increase more prevalent
on the eastern side of the southern part
of the state
it did require
some significant changes in the
districts uh to reach
um that equal population that our
constitution talks about and the federal
law talks about
uh one of those things that
we looked at
right off the bat i think i
mentioned it in one of the special
committee hearings
of the joint committees between the
house and the senate
was that manchester
uh had almost the perfect population for
having just two senate districts
uh and that nashua
uh
their population if they remained in
the number of wards that they had
and those awards were distributed out
with equal population
made it very difficult to maintain the
system as it is
one of the groups that represented
they
put forth a
and the idea that we could
have a population deviation in nashua
between
uh that and the ideal population of uh
eight percent or very close to that
which
certainly did not please me much
but
again that's what nashua did and they
enacted it so the nashua
wards
were broken down in the senate districts
along those populations
i
certainly
think that they could have done better
for the population
or for the people in new hampshire
than they did
certainly people have asked me what was
the criteria how did you make this
decision how did you make that decision
and i'll tell you that and the criteria
uh certainly we looked at a whole bunch
of things uh but that when you're trying
to do
um
an equal population uh deviation between
the various sens districts
and you have that as your your one of
your highest principles
that
it answers some of those questions once
you get below that and you say well i
have a choice between this community
that community looking at population of
how you group them together looking at
communities of interest types including
the
former government that they have chosen
you know sb2 towns uh traditional uh
towns uh with the traditional town
meetings uh the cities the
um
the school districts as the uh
the mapping people had suggested we we
looked at some of that we looked at a
lot of different things and because each
one of those communities are different
it was different each time we drew a map
and there were a lot of maps that
actually got drawn
but for
various reasons
we're never publicized we're never put
out
uh certainly we took in consideration
the the testimony of the various people
in the towns when you know from the
public hearings and i did attend all ten
of those
uh
public hearings uh i may be the only one
on both the house and the senate that
actually made it to all ten uh it was a
little difficult uh uh up in uh
when we were up in um uh conway i think
it was uh the uh
construction up there on the roads
caused a little delay and
but uh we did make it to all of them uh
i'm here for a minute and then i'm gonna
be across the street so if you have
anything
uh ask me now and i'll be back
at 10 30 or whenever is appropriate for
the for the next hearing
representative webber
thank you madam chair and thank you
senator for taking my question
as you know i am from cheshire county
and i have a concern because
i wonder uh
what the rationale was for putting
cheshire county into four different
senatorial districts
well again as i said that one of the
highest priorities that we had was
getting that population equal and then
as we were able to make that different
population in fact um
i i
the name of the town escapes me one of
the last things i did where you see
where the interface between uh senate
district eight and senate district
uh 10 that little elbow-shaped uh town
there uh that's one of the last things
that i did before i sent the map forward
and that actually reduced my my
population deviation uh
by you know several tenths of a percent
uh so again
uh
you know it
people have said well gee the maps are
jaggedy and this and that but if you
really are trying to get that population
correct
in my opinion uh in accordance with um
part one article nine of the
constitution which does talk about
representative districts but has been
applied to all of the the redistricting
we do um we worked hard to get that
population
um
to a number that that we could support
follow up madam chair follow up
and of particular concern to me um is
senate district nine
which you said you you
uh were concerned with communities of
interest
i note that senate district 9 runs from
hinsdale on the connecticut river
which is a small uh town and
all the way over to bedford which is a
very different large town on the other
you know more than halfway across the
state
and
i
wonder why
having been intimately involved in doing
senatorial maps 10 years ago
it's much easier than doing house maps
because the deviations are much easier
to satisfy
and i
this this town appears to me to be the
very essence of gerrymandering so
was there no other possible way to have
kept communities of interest together
there are thousands of ways to keep
communities of interest together and
thousands of ways to look at this map
that the testimony that we heard
in sullivan county was gee
we have a very close association with
the people in vermont we share services
we share schools we share a lot of
things
across that border the people that we
heard down in the southern part of the
state said well our economy is very much
in tune with the people in massachusetts
and so that once you go and look at
those populations that
if i'm not saying communities of
interest is the highest thing
on my list but population is and then i
look at those the input that we got from
the various communities about who they
did want to be associated with and even
though we may try to do something
i'll tell you i could tear any map that
anybody put apart and cast aspersions on
it and say it's gerrymandered and say
it's
this map
the population deviation
is i believe 7.5 percent
a lot of that population deviation is
due to the things that were done
by the nashua community
in the way that they redistricted
and are not you really can't change them
if you're going to do
the five or six different awards in
nashua to put them together
uh you just can't do it
so there's if we want to sit sit and
take pot shots at any particular map
you draw a map you let me take pot shots
i can do the same thing
questions from other members of the
committee
representative wilhelm
thank you madam chair thank you senator
for joining us and for taking my
question uh i'm curious i represent
manchester awards one two and three
um curious why
uh
ward one
is separated from the the rest of the
city well one of the criteria that was
used many many years ago
when i was probably younger than you
was to group
communities together such that you had
uh one or more sitting senators
representatives whatever districts that
you were using against each other okay
and so we look at manchester and we look
at
like goffstown and other communities and
that if you take a a
a larger portion of manchester and put
it up against one of those other
communities
they have an undue influence in my
opinion
on who's going to get elected in that so
the original intent was to take and make
manchester just two senate districts
but that would have put uh two
of the senators uh uh competing against
each other since there are currently uh
three democratic senators that live in
manchester uh i did not
in any other place on that map i did not
put
uh two
sitting senators uh in opposition with
each other unless the senators had
expressed to me uh that they
were looking at a change
point in fact is
district two
the senator from district two said that
he was looking at moving further
south and east in his district
so that
that allowed us to take district one and
come down into the area of the state
where he currently lives
but again that was one of the things
that we did not want to do
uh unlike some of the other maps that uh
that were out there uh that have been
proposed by various groups uh that one
of them i saw had had three sitting
senators um sitting you know in the same
district so you know what are you going
to get you're going to
are we going to call that gerrymandering
or not well
again that's one of the things that i
tried to avoid in making these maps
further questions from committee members
representative lane
thank you um
senator
are you saying that you took incumbents
into account over other criteria
absolutely
follow up madam chair
certainly
um can you comment on why that is not
seem to be a problem in the
congressional maps that have been drawn
and recommended by the governor there is
differences in the eligibility
for state offices where you have to live
in your district and federal offices for
especially congressional districts
but we're not here to talk about the
congressional districts but you do not
need to actually live in a congressional
district to run in that district case in
point
was
mr sanders who ran
uh two years ago
in a district that he did not live in
further questions from committee members
seeing none
um i'm going to open the floor to
comment on sb 240. um senator gray
it has other things to do senator gray
if you can stay here until 10 30 um the
people who have signed up to speak on
240 have also signed up to speak on 241
so my preference would be to start to
take public testimony now for 10 minutes
and if you can stay then break in the
public testimony go into
your second bill before us at 2
241 as noticed and then after you
present that bill
we can let you take care of the rest of
your day and we can continue to hear
testimony on both bills as you wish
thank you all right um thank you senator
gray for introducing to 40
also signed signed up to speak on 240 is
olivia zink and
ms inc i'll leave it to you as to
whether or not you want to just address
240 or or both of them at this point
excuse me madam chair she cannot address
the other one
i didn't officially open it so that's
thank you representative webber okay so
testimony for 240. correct um my name is
olivia zing the executive director for
open democracy action we're a
nonpartisan nonprofit organization which
has 35 000 members here in new hampshire
and we work on democracy and i live in
franklin
and i'm a mother of a 12 year old
daughter and my 12 year old daughter
will be voting
in six years
and these maps will be the things that
she she gets to inherit
as a first-time voter um so the the you
know just a reminder that these maps are
for 10 years
i
thank you for the opportunity to to
oppose senate bill 240.
um i think that this bill
doesn't take into consideration what's
best for the majority of voters in new
hampshire which are the undeclared
voters and public criteria
is very important
these maps have sprawling districts
which are not compact
this increases the margin to win
republicans can win 15 almost 16 of
these
senate districts
are lean republican which locks in a
supermajority
for republicans
this ignores communities of interest
like regional high schools and splits 35
high school saus
this packs districts with voters
both in the minority and majority
parties it puts college towns like
lebanon and hanover and plymouth into
senate district 5
leaving those adjacent districts more
conservative
um it has a somewhat
high deviation
um
and i think most of this is actually
contributed to the
national award lines splitting
manchester into three districts where it
could be
evenly split into two districts
there are only three competitive
senate district and zero very
competitive district
i want to speak to the senate district
that i live in
it puts the city of franklin in a
district that goes to orange which is uh
in the upper valley most of the people
in orange go shopping in lebanon
and it goes down to hillsboro
and so
i would say that most of the triangle
that represents franklin orange and
hillsborough
don't have a lot in common
um and you also can't get there from
one town to another unless you like hike
over mount cardigan
which is one way to get to orange
but the roads don't really take you
there
and then i wanted to speak to senate
district 9
which is a lean republican
district which stretches now from the
vermont border to hinsdale all the way
to bedford and it's one town deep
and i just want to point out that i
don't think hinsdale and bedford have a
lot in common as far as communities of
interest
i really want to urge this committee to
work towards a solution that works for
both parties
that if 50 of the voters vote republican
and 50 percent of the voters vote
democrat that we could get a map that
works for both parties instead of
one party getting 16 seats and the other
party getting eight seats
and with that i'm happy to take
questions and i have copies of my
written testimony that i can hand around
great thank you if you can just pass why
don't you just give that to
representative roulard and we'll get it
passed around questions from committee
members
representative lane thank you um
did you
propose a senate map open democracy to
the senate in the same way that you did
to us here in the house
yes the mapathon team has proposed maps
um david andrews who's our lead mapper
is here today and can speak to the
mapathon proposals and we'll have copies
of all of that analysis for you as well
further
um is the deviation um significantly
greater in the open democracy map than
it was
mr andrews has signed up to speak right
oh yeah okay thank you
i'll pepper him okay thank you
he's much better at answering deviation
questions than i am
much better at the math
all right
further questions
representative mcgee
and welcome back to election thank you
thank you so much
i don't even know what committee i'm in
anymore
thank you madam chairman and thank you
for taking my question
uh you've testified um
given some examples around uh how
community of interests
uh concerns or have not been adequately
addressed in some of the sections i
wonder if you could say anything about
the um
the overall fairness indifference to
other maps that have been presented to
the committee for consideration
for the voters you did allude to
how independent voters might be
not served as well by this map could you
say a little more about that so we can
understand it
um
yeah i'll try to attack that question i
think new hampshire is a very purple
state
where the majority of voters are
undeclared voters and we know undeclared
voters can swing elect elections and
when you do analysis of maps you can
look at different years of elections
based on
you know what what swings different
voters and so
um i think the district urine has swung
has been mostly republican for the last
10 years but has swing swung democrat at
least once if the senate district and i
believe that senate district is very
similar
um
this decade this proposal decade as it
was the the prior decade
and i think that when we look at maps we
really want to make sure voters
say i'm going to the polls because i
feel like my vote matters
not i'm doesn't matter which candidate i
choose for senate because there's
already a preordained outcome
and it's really important that there's
faith and integrity in the process
and i believe that in some of these
senate districts some voters might look
at the map and say i don't believe my
vote matters whether i'm a republican
in lebanon and i'd say it doesn't matter
who i vote for as a republican in
lebanon because the republican candidate
in lebanon has no chance of winning that
district with new london and
and
plymouth and lebanon
and dartmouth's packed into that
district whereas a district
somebody a democratic voter in a
different district might feel like their
vote for a senate candidate might not
matter
follow-up
it's it's the question of a novice since
i did not serve on the redistricting
committee but
my question is whether or not the
um the calculus of uh competitiveness is
even one of the criterium that's used
my understanding is there's been no
criteria that's been publicly released
and i do think that next decade it would
be really helpful to have public
criteria released on how this these
maps are drawn senator gray talked about
some of the criteria he used as far as
protecting incumbents is one of those
criterias but i think
i did not see a list of public criteria
representative weber
thank you madam chair and thank you for
being here today and taking my question
would you agree with me that
my constituents in hinsdale which is the
farthest town to the southwest in our
state
might be
considerably aggrieved at a district
which joins them to a very large
population center which is almost in
nashua
and
that they might feel
that no matter who wins this district
although we know who's going to win this
district
that they might not be well served by a
senator who is not as they are now from
cheshire county
but from somewhere all the way over near
nashua which is where the population is
yes i do agree that voters in hinsdale
might feel
that a senator
would not rep i would hope that a
senator would feel like they represent
every town in their district
um but i could see that it easily that a
senator could focus their attention on
those bedford towns
um and not make it all the way across
the state i think that it's also the
roads don't go
exactly like 101 does not travel exactly
that route to get
from hinsdale
it's a little tricky further questions
from committee members
that question was pretty speculative i
allowed it but
i'm going to ask committee members to
try to ask questions that people would
actually have a basis for responding
any further questions
thank you
um it is it is now 10 30. i'm going to
put the public hearing on 2 40 into
recess and i'm going to recognize
senator gray to introduce 241 to the
committee welcome
senator gray
thank you very much uh for the record i
am james gray i represent senate
district six which starts in rochester
goes up route 11 into uh belknap county
uh alton barnes said in gilman
uh certainly
one of the things that we heard from the
public hearings
was
how gerrymandered and i'll use quotes
around that
uh the
executive council district sure
again if you are really trying to do
what the law
says and get the populations as equal as
possible
sometimes the maps get messy sometimes
you end up
with things that stretch out
so one of the things that we did try to
do is to take a good look at that
the population deviation i believe for
the map without any changes using the
new census data
was approximately 2.7
[Music]
we looked at
several different maps
how that could be
uh accomplished um
and
again
uh not trying to protect
any incumbent
but to make sure that we didn't
intentionally have
two incumbents running against each
other
which is one of the criteria in your
ncls book
that you i think all got on election you
go into the chart on the back in the
various states that have criteria for
redistricting
is one of the ones that's listed there
it's not gerrymandering it's
what i consider to be the opposite of
gerrymandering it is making sure
that
someone doesn't decide well
you know this one and this one we're
gonna we're gonna have these two
democrats run off against each other
uh that's certainly not
not the intent of what i did and it is
the opposite we tried to make sure that
that didn't happen
um but sometimes things get messy
so the resulting map that you sit in
front uh see in front of you
there was a lot of people that wanted
this wanted that one of the other things
i need to be able to count to 13 in the
senate
to get things passed
and it took a long time unfortunately
the
map that you see in front of you was not
put together in time to have a separate
public hearing
in the senate
but it does a lot of the things that we
were told
in both the hearings that we held across
the state and each one of the counties
and what we heard in the other public
hearings that was held
on the map
that
is currently invoked on those
communities
this shifts
some of the population down into the
area where
the
line of population
has
representative uh said you know a single
line going across
uh which in fact doesn't make it bad it
just says that's the way it is and
uh so it shifts part of that population
from
district one down into that area and
then does what the people up in sullivan
county said to do
is that
they felt that they had an association
with vermont and keeping them together
and
an association with vermont
that was beneficial to them
we tried to not do
very much in
districts three and four
to keep them
relatively the same
and 5
again due to those population
not any other nefarious thing
but
due to population trying to get
those maps very close and in fact the
population was uh
uh i guess it's not quite half but it's
closer to half of what the deviation
would have been at 2.7 i think it's one
something i i the number escapes me
right now
uh but uh
remember that the thing that's in law
you know you go back
and
populations as equal as possible
practical you can go look the word up
in the constitution
these people that talk about compactness
these people that talk about other
things
to show to me in the law and i probably
would have done different things
but
that's not in law
law is population population population
and if you look at the supreme court
decision
manchester v gardener
and you look at it uh certainly it's
clear in there
and we certainly did use that as a
reference
in the things that we did with the
various maps
thank you questions representative weber
thank you madam chair uh
would you agree with me as a matter of
first principles that
an affinity with vermont for the river
towns has nothing to do with
redistricting because there are still
going to be river towns and vermont is
still going to stay where it is
i will not agree with you what i
my testimony was
is that at the hearings in sullivan
county
that was a request
now another question a valid request i
guess you can take that up with the
people at the hearing that made that
request but
we did listen to them and we do know
that there are
many of things that do happen across the
border and across the river
and
in fact
a lot of times people cross the border
to go down
the the road so that they can come back
into hampshire and that's actually
you know quicker for them than traveling
just the roads in new hampshire so there
is an association be whether you like it
or not it was expressed in the hearings
follow-up
okay i'll leave that one um
this next question is not a not
speculative because it's a matter of
population and the way the lines were
drawn
so
isn't it true that as the maps are
currently drawn
with the population being very much
in the south of both district 2 and
district 1
that it is conceivable that the north
country will wind up with no effective
representation whatsoever under this map
could you please define effective
representation
uh isn't it true that you may have one
counselor from
concord and one counselor from over in
the very farthest
south
east corner both of whom are from larger
metropolitan areas which have look very
unlike
most of the north country as it is now
constituted i think the committee can
stipulate that rural communities are
different than metropolitan areas
senator gray do you want to answer that
question or not i certainly you know by
looking at this map
i can draw a very small circle um that
you know would encompass part of uh one
part of two part of
four and part of five
uh or any other combination of four of
those and
you know cover it with a probably a 50
cent piece the way this map is
is printed so
is it possible
yeah
but who's making the choice
the voters in the state of new hampshire
are making the choice and
to say that a population deviation of
under two
is not preferable to a population
deviation of three or four
is ridiculous and one final matter one
final follow-up
my final follow-up is
the observation that isn't it true that
because we are only dealing with five
districts and many many many towns there
are any number of ways that you could
have put this together unlike the house
maps where it's very difficult
where you would have achieved the same
population
or better and
probably not better it's pretty good for
deviation
and not
confused the communities of interest to
the extent that this map does
you had me representative weber until
you said confused communities of
interest could you rephrase that
madam chair if if you want to go ahead
and answer it go ahead briefly please
senator i will stipulate that there are
probably millions of ways
to do this map
my job
and
again i looked for the the supreme court
decision manchester v gardner
about what they did when they were
looking at the various maps and saying
okay where do i start where where do i
go
okay and decisions get made
a decision in manchester and a decision
in nashua
can make a big impact on
other portions of this map and when
you're looking at population
we took into consideration the the wants
and that we could from the various
hearings that we held we did our best
this is the map in front of you
it is not the 99
999 other ones that could be drawn
further questions from the committee
representative wilhelm
thank you madam chair senator thanks for
taking my question um it's my
understanding that
this bill came out of the election law
committee in the senate uh with the
districts the current districts still
intact
and then there was a floor amendment
uh which is what we're reviewing today
what prompted the floor amendment what
why why a floor amendment after
the
districts that were
you know put through the election law
committee
there was consensus at that time what
what happened between
the committee meeting and the time the
bill hit the floor of the senate
i can tell you that uh if you go back
through the hearings and various
things that that happened in the
committee
that there are
there were people
and the testimony both in the senate
hearings and the hearings across the
state
that something be done with district two
but again as i mentioned before
you need to count to 13 to be able to
pass anything in the senate
so we continue to work on that we
continue to try to improve it we
continue to try to get that population
down further than the 2.7
that population that was in the map that
was voted out of the committee
and
we were able to achieve that
and then
that uh prompted a four floor amendment
because of procedure
further questions from committee members
representative mcgee
thank you madam chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question um my
question relates to the fair maps effort
i attended
my county's redistricting meeting and i
also
know the person in my town who presented
a warrant article at our last town
meeting which passed and i understand
it's about 74 towns past warrant
articles asking for fair maps and i
understand that the word fair is in the
eye of the beholder perhaps but i
believe that the mapathon effort
worked to try and supply maps that were
fair in that they were
not
designed to help any party but rather to
advantage the voter and i wonder if you
could speak to
the
the map that you've given here as to how
how it
how it stands up against the other maps
that were presented i know you've said
you could do it a million different ways
it's true
there are many ways to slice up a map
but i think we i think the committee was
presented with maps that were
um more fair than this map that we're
looking at right now
and i wish you could speak to that
i don't know what more fair means i know
what what legal means i know what the
constitution says about equal population
i know that many of the maps that were
presented from the fair map people had
errors in them that i pointed out to
them
one of the maps had a town
for
this particular map i believe
that was
misplaced in the district when we were
looking at retaining the stuff i know
that they prove they wanted nashua and
proposed to nashua that they have a
population deviation of eight
approximately eight down in nashua which
certainly in my opinion doesn't follow
the state constitution in trying to get
equal population as equal as you can
they have
an agenda that said that we need to keep
school districts together i will tell
you that
i have been a representative i have been
a school board member i have been a city
councilman and i have been a senator and
as i move up the chain
school districts become
less a thing that that i need to
associate real closely with
uh as i go up and so
trying to take that school thing and
saying
i'm going to make a congressional map
because i'm going to move this town
because it keeps the school district
together
uh
it did not pass the common sense with
tests with me
that when i was a school board member
absolutely okay when i was a city
councilman
yeah i want to keep that in but as i get
to be a representative and more broad
interpretation and now as a senator
it's just not a practical criteria thank
you senator further questions from
committee members representative weber
are keeping counties together no longer
a consideration for you because i
noticed that these districts
have very little respect for county
lines or
the concerns of people on the county
level which is a much broader level than
the school district two things i'd like
to say about that i represent two
counties right now stafford county and
belknap county i think that going to the
various meetings that i do in both
counties gives me a better perspective
of what the general population across
the two counties that i represent
i also want to point out that when
mapathon
[Music]
started this
and they started to look at communities
of interest i was told by one of their
representatives that their original list
of communities of interest contained
more than 60 items
and that those were winnowed down to the
ones that you see in the maps so just as
i could have another 10 000
you know different maps i can also have
another combination of communities of
interest that were at least something
that they can they considered as
communities of interest when they
started to do the maps
further questions from committee members
representative lane
thank you madam chair um senator
uh
i agree that defining a fair map is
a difficult process
would you agree that a fair mat means
that the district is as competitive as
possible
no
and let me explain that
okay
if i go and stick a pin in portsmouth
and i try to make a map that's
competitive
uh portsmouth is
uh lean's very very democratic and if i
try to make it competitive by going
somewhere and i'm not quite sure where
to make it competitive i have done a
disservice to those people in portsmouth
if i stick a pin in belknap county
we'll say
up in
[Music]
alton for example and i try to make that
a competitive district
there's not a whole lot of things that
you can do to make it a competitive
district and i have done
a disservice i believe that that is also
in the definition of gerrymandering
saying that i'm going to make this thing
competitive no matter what
the basis of the people are no matter
what the population is and if you're
going to expand your definition of
gerrymandering the way
some of the representatives have
have
expressed opinions today uh then that
would also fall into your definition of
gerrymandering further questions from
committee members madam chair
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair senator um
just a question
the existing population in the five
council districts
currently has a deviation of 2.27
without doing any changes at all
did the senate take into consideration
that they didn't need to redistrict at
all
the senate certainly did take that into
consideration the senate and the hearing
that was held in the senate was a
hearing on the map as unchanged but
there were people
probably some of the same people you'll
hear from today that still pointed to
district 2 and said district 2 because
it is one town long and stretches from
the west side of the state to the east
side of the state wanted to see a change
we were able to find a map
that was presented in the floor
amendment that you see in front of you
that reduced that population deviation
further making us more compliant with
the state constitution
and producing a map that you see in
front of you thank you senator further
questions from committee members
none thank you for being with us this
morning senator gray
it was a pleasure
all right so at this point i will reopen
the hearing on 3 40
um
and we will also continue now with 241
in regards to the hearing on the bill we
just heard executive council districts
um i'm going to recognize olivia zink
because she was the only person who got
to speak on 240. um i i believe pretty
much everybody that i've gotten a pink
card has signed up to speak on both
bills um so i'm going to give everybody
the opportunity to speak to both bills
when they come up and i'm going to ask
that testimony be limited to five
um six minutes because you're going to
be testifying on two bills and we'll let
you know when you're at five minutes
um so um thank you
ms inc and welcome back up again and the
paperwork will be passed around and i
think it got stopped somewhere the last
time so if we can just
pass the written testimony out from
people when we get it
that would be great
good morning representative griffin and
members of the special committee on
redistricting for the record my name is
olivia zink executive director for open
democracy
i'm a pro-voter pro-voter nonpartisan
organization based in concord and i live
in franklin
i want to first before i start my
testimony just comment on
senator gray's example of using
portsmouth to create a safe republican
district
he
exactly did that in the executive
council districts
so uh it is possible to make portsmouth
a safe republican district and they have
done that um in that executive
council district such so executive
council district one
changes when i think under undergoes the
most amount of changes in this map
um
including
claremont
hanover lebanon littleton
in grafton county also putting parts of
coos carroll belknap counties
over in to the other districts
district 2
also
undergoes a lot of changes i talk about
them specifically in my testimony and
since you have that in front of you
but i think it's really it does lose a
whole portion
from the current executive council maps
so we are no longer a geographical
executive council districts
um
these maps have been
reshaped and i kind of think of that as
a little bit of an e you come from
littleton you go into concord and then
you go down to peterborough
um
packing as many democratic towns as they
possibly could into that executive
council district
um
too
district three remains exactly the same
as the as the other districts
um in my testimony i do talk about
um what the governor has said on new
hampshire public radio in the exchange
about the executive council maps
um and i think it's important that the
whatever this body decides that they're
we don't get stuck in a place
and also in my testimony i do talk about
this is the first time
this this meeting right now is the first
time the public has had a chance
to give input on this proposal
um when the public hearing was in the
senate there was a different senate
proposal for the executive council map
so this is the first time
in the process that the public has been
able to give input on this specific map
and i again think um urge you to amend
this map so that you're serving all
voters
and then you also have testimony from
joanne emis and hollis ian burke and
in keene ellen farnham and tamworth and
catherine
in sunapee
that i also handed out who could not be
here today
thank you um i have a question i have
written
oh they're stapled together that's
what's being passed out now i held it
because i didn't know what i had all
right so this is further i think we
might have gotten emails from
from some of them may have emailed their
testimony but i know that there may be a
vote on this so i wanted to make sure
their testimony got in front of you
for today no thank you i appreciate it
any questions for ms zink
seeing none thank you very much
also i also signed up to speak today on
these bills um and on both bills is
linda bundy
good morning madam chair and members of
the special committee on redistricting
i didn't bring printed copies but i did
email you
um when drawing we just and this is with
respect to sp240
when drawing redistricting maps
population deviation limits are mandated
by the state constitution
citizens of new hampshire attended
public hearing sessions in each county
and submitted additional criteria beyond
the mathematics of population that they
believed to be essential considerations
when creating the maps
most often cited were high school saus
shared emergency services
water and sewer systems and public
health
facilities while the maps in sb 240 do
meet population deviation requirements
they fall short with respect to best
practices in redistricting and applying
the criteria requested by granite
staters
the 2010 senate map already reflected
partisan advantage
in 2020 the election results were
divided 50-50 between republicans and
democrats but the senate seat split was
14 republicans and 10 democrats
the map proposed by sb 240 would have
resulted in greater partisan advantage
in the 2020 elections yielding 15
republican seats and nine democratic
some towns that lean democratic have
been packed into nine districts while
others have been split among the
remaining 15 districts
in my region of the state hillsborough
county towns of hancock and peterborough
have been moved into district 10 making
it more democratic at the same time
causing my own district 8 and also
district 9 to lean more republican
district 5 is packed with three
democratic college towns that are
presently in separate districts
compactness is a best practice that can
keep communities of interest intact
the proposed map has a low compactness
score when analyzed by
dra 2020 and splits 36 high school saus
keeping saus intact was the single most
important community of interest
criterion requested by citizen input
district 9 is decidedly not compact
being one town wide from hinsdale to
bedford across
73 miles excuse me
i believe that the maps proposed by sb
240 are not in the best interest of the
citizens of new hampshire
i ask you to amend them
thank you and with respect to sb 241
the executive council maps of 2010 have
served as a poster child for
gerrymandering the proposed maps and sb
241 look better but in reality are more
partisan
district 2 no longer stretches across
the state from west to east however it
does reach north to littleton and
carroll west to concord and peterborough
and south to hinsdale and winchester
district 2 leans more heavily democratic
and district 1 is more republican than
before
districts 3 4 and 5 are somewhat
competitive but lean republican the
voices of voters matter
a recent unh poll indicates that 80
percent of voters do not think the
strict maps are fair
certainly for republicans in district 2
and democrats in district 1 votes will
not weigh equally
these maps also split 17 high school
saus and also 9 of 10 counties are split
i believe that these maps do not serve
granite staters well i ask you to amend
amend these maps to draw maps that do
thank you for your consideration of my
testimony
thank you
any questions for miss bundy
she tries to escape all the time before
i ask that question she comes in front
of election too
all right thank you um also signed up to
speak on these bills is karine dodge
i think thank you i'm having a hard
you time wanted to
welcome good morning
good morning geography and members
i believe i'm speaking on 240 first is
that correct you can go i have every
confidence the committee can keep
together the difference between the
executive council and senate maps so
where i can is my well that's somewhat
true
my name is corrine dodge i'm a voter in
derry new hampshire and i thank you for
giving me the opportunity to testify
against sb 240 for the proposed senate
redistricting map
i believe that we can all agree that
redistricting is a rather time consuming
and expensive process
and that the purpose of redes
districting is to even out the number of
voters in each district because of
population changes during the past 10
year period
ethically this process should be done as
fairly and as transparently as possible
to give all voters a chance to be heard
ideally a district's population would be
evened out by grouping communities of
interest like high school saus together
this district this way districts can
elect officials who will effectively
represent their communities
and that's the most important part not
whether it's saus it's whether they can
effectively
represent the people that voted in that
district that's the most crucial part in
my mind
the minority and mapathon independent
citizens mapping project proposed maps
do a better job of keeping saus together
and of creating compact districts
so that those those representatives can
represent their constituents
these proposals i'm sorry these proposed
proposals should be considered and i ask
you to do so
the purpose of redistricting
should not be to silence voters voices
nor should it be a one-sided political
party scramble to assure the election
the re-elections of as many incumbent
senators from the majority party as
possible
and if 50 percent of new hampshire
voters vote democrat and 50 percent vote
republican in the next election
with the maps being considered today the
result would be
a consistent 16 to 8 veto proof majority
if 50 of voters vote for one party and
50 for the other the senate should be a
12 12 split
not a gerrymandered
6 to 18
vote
that's what i call gerrymandering when
the results come out consistently
16 to 8
when it's small
when it's more likely mathematically to
be 12 to 12
split
i ask that you support all new hampshire
voters by amending sb 240 and i thank
you
thank you um
should i do them yeah do them both and
then i'll ask for questions oh i'm sorry
i forgot i'm supposed to ask questions
i'm still not used to how this is this
is we're doing this a little differently
i know that i know that and i'm very
nervous as i always am so
you do a terrific job you should not be
nervous we we know you're always
prepared so welcome and
2 41.
good morning chad graham and members and
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to testify my name is corinne dodge
and i am a voter in derry
i am asking you to vote against sb 241
for the proposed executive council map i
have two reasons for this request
one of them has already been stated is
that we haven't had a public hearing on
it and i believe that's important
and it was voted on without that
so i won't go into
into that any further i think that's
already been stated
i admit that sb 241 clearly changes the
look
of what i call the gerrymandered 2010
executive council map with its dragon
district 2 design however
the partisan intent intent is still the
same allowing the majority party to gain
political power over the opposing party
that's wrong whether who's in charge and
who's the opposing party
in my mind
district 2 still collects democratic
leading towns just going up the ritter
river instead of across the state
with so many democratic leaning towns
republican voters in district two
are basically meaningless and olivia
zinke did a really good job of
describing what it feels like to be a
voter in a district that you know your
vote is not even going to count so why
bother
sorry
likewise
district 4 leans republican
making it hard for democrats in this
district to have their voices heard
is this what democracy should be about
protecting political parties over voters
do away with this funny-looking dragon
map and voila the problem of
gerrymandered map magically goes away no
no it doesn't
we all know that
what we need is competitive maps where
legislators work hard to represent all
their constituents
where voters
have a fair say in who will represent
them
their interests
i urge the committee to amend
whatever it is
i forgot that
that was the executive council you were
talking about so thank you see we were
paying attention we know any questions
from ms dodge
and you've gotten emails from us dodge
also thank you thank you
also signed up to speak on this is liz
tentarelli
thank you madam chair and committee for
this opportunity to speak my name is liz
tentarelli i'm president of the league
of women voters of new hampshire a
nonpartisan organization
that's been involved in the fight for
fair maps here in new hampshire since at
least 2004.
so we're not newcomers to this things
don't surprise us
we get very actively involved but i will
say right now i'm very discouraged i'm
very discouraged by these two maps
early in this process the chair of this
committee said it's all about the
numbers
and the chair of the senate committee
said the numbers work out when
presenting one of the maps
if that were true if this were only all
about the numbers
i don't think the maps would look this
way
we know that on a national level we get
congressional you know
the constitution says we have to do this
pennsylvania lost a seat california lost
a seat
texas gained two and there were some
other changes
so we expect changes
but let me talk about the executive
council map first uh i was very
surprised to see that the original
proposal that came out of the special
redistricting committee was for the same
map that we have mocked since 2011 when
it was adopted
as being obviously gerrymandered with
district two tortured to become democrat
and the other four strongly leaning
republican
and so i said to a colleague when i
heard there might be a change there
might be an amendment i said well how
much worse can they make it all right
sorry i get a little cynical at times
um
this one is worse
district 2 now is even more strongly
democrat than the district 11 i'm sorry
district 2 that came out of 2011.
five towns with
significant size colleges have been
crammed into district 2
with their attendant liberal voters and
liberal professors and so on
but more than that district 2
includes the town of hanover which of
course is a college town it is also the
the hometown
of the candidate that held
the
district one executive council seat
twice in the last 10 years
not the current incumbent but somebody
who won two elections to hold that seat
that candidate no longer stands a chance
in district one which he represented for
four years
because the lines had been drawn so the
idea of what senator gray said of
protecting incumbents
not protecting exactly but rather
respecting this we didn't want fights
between incumbents obviously doesn't
apply
to some people who held the seat well in
the past
in my written testimony i attached a
a page at the end i even paid for color
printing folks i rarely do this we are
so cheap
um
this is the results of an
study of the lien of the senate seats
from 1994
through
2014.
it doesn't go beyond that because this
report came out in 2016
and i am not smart enough mathematically
to update this
but what you can see in this colored
chart is that for years
the senate
has won a disproportionate number of
seats
disproportionate to the overall vote so
if you ignore the efficiency gap for a
bit because
i'm not going to try to explain that
just look at the number of seats shown
in red for republican blue for democrat
obviously
and within the circle it shows the
percent that the voters got
and we go
it's just unbalanced
uh so that we have a state
where
more people are undeclared than
republican or democrat but when you look
at the overall 2020 election results you
realize that we are still a purple state
the votes tend to go republic half
republican half democrat
not so with the senate seats
and in the new senate map that has been
proposed
an analysis shows that there are now
only four competitive seats for the
senate
that it is very likely even with that
evenly split republican democrat vote in
the next election
there will be 15 republican seats out of
24. 15 to 9 is very likely
and i've mentioned some districts in
there that are most
heavily leaning one way or the other
in this republican map
so when the
committee chairs say it's all about the
numbers i'm
skeptical i think it's all about the
partisan lien
what that means is that voters next fall
if these maps go into effect
will have only one opportunity to really
have their vote count and that is in the
primary
and i don't know that we want that to
happen typically we get about a 15
voter turnout in primary elections
people especially with over 400 000
undeclared voters in the state they
don't pay that much attention to
primaries
and yet
these maps predetermine the outcome
whoever wins the primary in many of
these districts whether it's senate or
executive council
will win the election
thank you if you could wrap up i am
wrapping i figured but i'm getting
people looking saying why aren't you
saying anything no no i'm wrapping up
i'm saying as a nonpartisan organization
i want all voters to have their voices
heard
and while i can't guarantee everybody
will vote in the primary i want those
votes to count in the general election
so i am wrapped up ms griffin and thank
you for this opportunity and if there
are questions i would be glad to answer
them as long as they don't ask me to
explain efficiency gap
questions for miss tentarelli
thank you for the for the color print
i'm always impressed by your paper which
is colored and so it sticks out
representative lane
thank you madam chair and thank you miss
centarelli
um
so how would you define a fair map
a fair map is a map in which all the
voters
get a chance to
elect the candidate of their choice in
the general election not just in the
primary
that isn't true when you get down to the
town level people live in democrat or
republican towns i quite realize that
but by the time we get up to the senate
and the executive council districts and
certainly the congressional districts
every vote should be
counted counted and have a fair chance
of being counted that's my idea of fair
maps
follow-up
thank you
is that also consistent with the numbers
in order to get the um
the diverse not diversity the
equalization of the population do you
think there's a way to balance that
between the two
i i think it's possible in the executive
council maps to have them drawn very
differently
i'm not sure about the senate maps i
think without torturing things terribly
there might be
safe senate districts for either
republicans or democrats
but we we ought to be able to manage it
at least for the executive council in in
in our discussion today
thank you
further questions for ms tentarelli
seeing none thank you very much
also signed up to speak on this bill is
sarah lobet loeb dell
right here
good morning um some of my
my
senate testimony is going around sp240
testimony is going around and then the
sp 241 is stapled to another packet the
one that olivia mentioned with other a
whole bunch of others oh all right with
that i think we already have thank you
okay
well
we don't have that many so
um
if you want to pass out the fair maps
that's fine right now because people
have referenced them
oh mapathon excuse me i have fair maps
they're the signs all say the same i
think they're fair too
i could ask some questions about fair
but i'm restraining myself all right uh
welcome
okay thank you uh
chair griffin and members of the house
special committee on redistricting my
name is sarah lobdell and i'm a voter in
keene new hampshire
thank you for taking my testimony i'm
going to speak to sb 240 and 241
specifically as they impact keene and
cheshire county
and i want to start off my sb 240 senate
map testimony with a poem
roses are red violets are blue new
hampshire is purple these maps should be
too
um
so if you look at i included a map of
the
image of the senate map in my testimony
and on this map keene is in district 10
and based on the mapathon's analysis
district 10 leans heavily democrat
so this means in district 10 that the
votes and the voices of republicans and
independents
are outnumbered and essentially
meaningless
they won't be able to have a fair shot
at electing a candidate that can focus
on their needs
furthermore
when districts are centered around
non-partisan communities of interest
candidates are also able to better meet
our needs as constituents
communities of interest grouped into
districts allow constituents to present
a united front to their senator to take
action on issues that are unique to
their communities
so for sb240 keen is in district 10
that is crisscrossed across a whole
bunch of communities of interest
let's see oh yeah okay so
lots of towns near keene are actually
split up into different districts in
cheshire county so i have friends who
live in winchester which is district 9
on sb240
they go to work in keene they attend
school in keene they shop in keene
i would argue that these folks probably
have more in common
and would be better represented by a
senator
uh who represents them in winchester and
keane at the same time
rather than grouping
keene in district 9 and folks in
surrounding towns in district 8 or 9.
um so on sb 240 um overall message i
urge the committee to please oppose 240
um and amend the senate districts to be
more competitive and centered around
communities of interest like high school
saus
so thank you for your time on 240.
um and then
uh 241 my name is sarah lovdell i'm a
voter in keene new hampshire thank you
for taking my testimony
again i'm going to speak to how sb 241
the executive districts impact keene
so again when districts are competitive
candidates must appeal to a wide range
of voters on the issues
and candidates are therefore more likely
to serve their constituents needs
so on sb 241 king is in district 2 with
a number of democrat-leaning towns
making it again more likely that a
democrat will be elected
and that the votes of republicans and
independents
will be meaningless as they'll be
outnumbered
all voters should have a fair shot at
electing candidates that can serve their
needs
so on the back of this testimony i have
the minorities proposal and the
mapathons proposal for your
consideration
the mapathon's proposal
um
well both the mapathon minority proposal
do a better job at making districts
competitive especially where keane lies
and
the last thing i want to say on 241
is that i believe i heard senator gray
earlier say that deviations of around
two or less
is what he was looking for and so
if you could please consider the
mapathon proposal the mapathon's
proposal have a population deviation of
2.47 so that's that's pretty close to
the
majority's proposal
uh thank you for your time please oppose
and amend sb241 to be more competitive
thank you thank you and thank you for
that comparison to the uh
mapathon map
representative mcgee
thank you madam chairwoman and thank you
for taking my question
um as i hear you speak and you appear to
be a young voter
uh as i hear you speak about your
district and you're concerned you're
into fine young
it's like defining woman i would not go
there
um okay so my question is uh
when you're talking about competitive
districts
and you're outlining a concern for
uh disenfranchising certain voters
because their vote won't count if a
district is going to swing one way or
the other
then you're going to feel like you know
you voting a different way doesn't
really matter
does that in your opinion
contribute to voter apathy among people
who are coming out to vote and turn out
in voting
um so your question is if if a district
leans heavily one way do
well folks not show up to vote because
they think their vote doesn't matter is
that yep um
i am not an expert on that but i would
say my my hunch as a young voter would
be that yes that folks um
often a lot of people that i know don't
vote in the primaries because they're
like oh the people who really care about
these issues will vote and then we'll
vote later in the general and so then in
the general um if you feel like you're
gonna show up but the other candidate
already
you're already outnumbered in terms of
voters for the other candidate people
yeah might not show up
and
follow up the other contin the other uh
contributing issue that i can see that i
would ask you about is
is whether a safe district
also contributes to
[Music]
not having the elected person be
responsible to the voters
um
so if yeah if a district is safe
will the um the senator or executive
council not be responsible to all voters
um that's yeah definitely potential if
they feel like they only need to focus
on like one tiny chunk of their
constituents and meet their needs and
maybe that's like the biggest city in
their really sprawly district they yeah
they might not focus on all of the other
constituents
thank you
thank you other questions from committee
members
seeing none thank you very much thank
you also signed up to speak on both the
bills we're considering this morning is
frank carnac
correct
welcome
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the opportunity to testify
today my name is frank knack i'm the
policy director with the aclu of new
hampshire
and we are here in opposition to both sp
240 and sb 241
um starting with sb 240 so we wanted to
make sure that we could provide
an independent data-driven analysis of
of the map
in the senate uh proposal
and so consultant contracted with an
outside firm to provide that independent
analysis and we can conclude from their
analysis uh that this is in fact a
partisan gerrymander
many of the points i wanted to discuss
have already been uh lifted up but i'll
just point out a few things in addition
um from the findings uh we conclude that
the partisan lead for democratic leaning
districts is plus 9.11
the partisan lien for uh gop leading
districts is point uh 5.04 so a
substantial difference there
and i also think it's important to note
um the the the um the scope or the size
of the partisan lien is is much much
greater for democratic leaning districts
than for republican leaning districts so
in terms of their their packing ability
was substantial on democrats
um
i'll point out that in ford there was
only four districts where it was above
10 points all four of those were
democratic leading districts
and in two of those it was not only
above 10 points it was actually 19 above
19 points
and also point out the highest
republican pac district was only 9.4 so
more than double
so i think it's important
that voters pick
their politicians and not the other way
around and with the senate map
the cinema fails to meet that basic test
on the um on the executive council we
are because there's a new proposal that
that's been brought we are still having
that analysis conducted
uh so i can just speak to the
preliminary findings that we have which
is that i think has been as alluded to
we have serious concerns particularly
with district 2 and in the extreme
packing there and i also think it's
important to recognize um from reports
that um it is our understanding that
executive council members actually asked
for this and so i think you can't get a
better example in that case
of politicians picking their voters and
not the other way around
so
i will be circulating the additional
analysis as soon as we get it back to
the full committee so that you all have
it in front of you as well as the uh the
original analysis that i mentioned happy
to answer any questions thank you before
i recognize committee members you
mentioned that you retained a firm to do
the analysis you do you have anything in
writing today for us for that analysis
yes i'll be circulating so um it was
flow analytics um and the reason i did
not provide before the hearing is we're
still waiting for the updated executive
council and so i wanted to make sure i
could send them together to the full
committee all right and so flow
analytics is the firm that you retained
yes and when did the senate pass the
senate and the executive council maps do
you recall that date i believe it was
the end of january around the end of
january early february i don't think
that's right i'm just going to look to
olivia do you know have the date
all right olivia what do you think of
february maybe but if you could let me
know the dates they were actually
approved by the senate that would be
terrific
all right questions from committee
members representative lane
uh thank you madam chair um since we are
probably going to vote on these today
could you please provide us with the
information as soon as possible
perhaps before the end of this hearing
so that we can have the advantage of
looking at it you can just email it to
the election law committee through the
website if you've got anything online if
you don't have copies
excuse me sorry i'm i'm sorry
representative lane well we have time to
review that before yes we're gonna have
a break okay
yeah so i will i will send the senate
version um it includes the senate and
the executive council the executive
council maps have been changed since
this you know i understand but so i'll
send you the center version yeah thank
you
thank you
other questions from committee members
see none thanks for joining us thank you
so much
also signed up to speak on this is david
erickson
david erickson from where new hampshire
um not being experienced at testifying i
only brought one
copy should i give it to you
representative
do you need it to testify from
and then you can give it to
representative roulard after you're done
would that help okay sure
thank you representative griffin and
senators
we're all representatives here
the senator has left the room
left the room
um i didn't intend to testify but i was
so outraged
by
senator gray's testimony that he could
assert that he was um
just trying to count to 13 i think he
counted to 15 at least
so i um
i'll testify first on
senate bill
241 which i do ask you all to vote
against
um
i'd live in where
i've taught in the ware school district
and also in the henniker school district
and
i would like a senator who
would be familiar with
the school districts
and care about their interests
and so having them in the same district
makes sense to me
um
[Music]
what do
i as a resident of where and my
neighbors and friends in dunbarton have
in common with those communities way
over on the connecticut
river
not much
and many republican friends of mine in
ware where
i feel would be
disenfranchised by
the district proposed
because
there's no real point in voting
for each individual with it being such a
certain thing that
the republican
candidate would win
i also wonder if ruth ward would really
want to have to travel that distance
in representing
her district
um
[Music]
at our town election
um
on the warrant was the fair maps
proposal and
overwhelmingly we voted for it
um
can this committee reasonably assert
that the proposed senate district maps
comply with
fair criteria
i don't think so
as for sb 241
uh i was
working with others in the town to put
together a candidate's night and we
hoped to include executive council
candidates dave wheeler and deborah
pignatelli at the time
and when i called deborah pignatelli
she said i'd love to come
but i really have to focus on nashua
that's where i
you know get the greatest bang for the
buck i'm not going to
gain enough votes in where to make it
worth my while
to come up that was very
dismaying to me it seems that if
districts were more balanced
than
those few votes that she could get in
the rural parts of
of that executive council district and
this was of course the old map um
it would have been more likely to see
her get to know her and for her to get
to know them
so um
it's a shame
that
for expediency
she felt the need to focus on nashua
pretty much to the exclusion of rural
communities
so please vote against these
gerrymandered maps
and give us
a fair shot
and uh make it so that we're all
fairly represented
thank you very much does anybody have
any questions for mr erickson
uh
mr erickson with if you're willing
representative weber has a question for
you
thank you mr erickson uh following on to
your comments of concern about the rural
districts
as i represent a rural district myself
would you agree with me that the
council maps that as drawn that we would
be voting on today
do an extreme disservice to north
country voters because
both
[Music]
one and two
also contain large population centers
and therefore
those may be the focus of candidates to
the exclusion of the entire north
country as the maps are drawn
from my limited experience down in
district five i would be afraid that
would be the same situation
thank you sir
further questions for mr erickson
seeing none thank you very much for
coming mr erickson and we have your
written testimony for the record
um the last person i have signed up for
this
um if there's anybody else who wanted to
speak they need to do a pink art is
david andrews i i never know whether to
have mr andrews come first with the
mapathon or or at last but everybody
seemed to know the work you've done so i
thought i would let you go last so you
could go through everything before we
break
welcome welcome back thank you
um for the record my name is david
andrews i'm from chichester i was the
lead mapper on the mapathon project
redistricting is
one of the most important things
that will be undertaken
by this body and by the legislature in
new hampshire it lasts for 10 years
so
eight-year-olds now will be voting on
these maps
and
the vote that you're about to take is
probably going to be the most important
one that you make as legislators
with redistricting
you can
choose
who you want to have as your
representatives
or you can let the voters choose
in that
it's a lot easier to move one town on a
map than it is to swing an electorate
by percentage points you know
it's much easier
to pack your opponents into districts
than it is to win over
their voters who
um usually vote for them
um
there's been a lot of talk today about
fair maps and what makes a fair map
and it's been difficult for a lot of
people um to define this both senator
gray and others
because we don't have criteria neither
this committee nor its counterpart in
the senate released criteria if you have
criteria
you can look at that and judge maps
against each other we've talked about
how there's thousands of maps that can
be created
but each are not equal and if you have
criteria you can rank them against each
other based on that criteria whether
it's population competitiveness
compactness
communities of interest any of those
things you can then rank those maps and
throw out the ones that don't come close
on any of those metrics that you decide
to use
what we did in the mapathon project was
we went out to the voters
to cons the residents of new hampshire
and asked what are important to you and
that's what we got we got a list of you
know 63 things that senator gray talked
about
that were important to to people
then we went back and asked people what
what's most important to you you know
when we got high school saus
local hospitals uh public health regions
county lines those things were the most
important things to the residents of new
hampshire and thus we went forward
and mapped according to those
uh
criteria
we didn't take competitiveness into
account until afterwards i drew hundreds
of maps and
never did i well
never did i
use competitiveness as a metric when i
was drawing a map that i wanted to put
forward i did
draw
gerrymanders on either side for fun um
specifically for the executive council
map and
remarkably the one that is put forth
today looks remarkably similar to the
republican gerrymander that i drew
probably five days after the 2020 census
was released
so what i would do would i would draw
according to the criteria and then
afterwards i would look and see if the
competitiveness looked reasonable you
know new hampshire being a 50 50 state
you would expect
you know 12 12
or 13 11 something like that in the in
the senate districts so that's what i
would do i would i would go use the
criteria figure out what
um
a map that met most of the criteria and
then look and see if it was um
competitiveness competitive or not
um and that's what i think should be
done and should be the process going
forward um
for this body
um the 2010 senate map now getting into
uh the the senate map
the 2010 senate map was already pretty
uh partisanly swung
you know it's been stated 50 50 in 2020
and it was a 1410 split
this
currently proposed map goes even further
when it doesn't need to
senator gray talked about how
the population changed so we needed to
make significant changes to
the 2010 map it's just not true
yes we need to make some changes if you
put the 2010 map uh with the 2020 census
you get a deviation of
13.47 percent um which is higher than
the 10 percent generally allowed by
courts
by moving 10 pounds
you can get that deviation to lower than
the 7.5 that they got
10 pounds
most of which are in the the north
country um swinging uh district one and
two around a little bit gets you most of
the way there
one of the most egregious uh
displays of gerrymandering is
in this current proposal is district 9
and 10.
they needed to be balanced there was
there was more people in district 9 than
district 10 and thus something needed to
be done
all you needed to do was move richmond
from district 9 to district 10 and it
balanced out those populations that's it
but instead
they moved peterborough and hancock into
district 10 which are democrat leaning
towns thus packing more democrats into
district 10
and swung district 9 all the way from
bedford to hinsdale 72 miles it takes
over two hours to drive it
and in doing so
created a new
more republican lean district rather
than the
[Music]
very competitive district district 9 had
been in the last six to eight
years um
this the the least changed map of just
10 towns would have um moved zero
incumbents out of their districts
instead of the the
20 or instead of the two that were moved
so if it was about um
if it was about protecting incumbents
this would have done that if it was
about getting the lowest population
deviation this would have done it
so
i
i can go through and talk about every
single little change i'm not going to
that the mat that was made on this
senate map
and each one of them
is made
to give a partisan advantage
to the majority party
um
moving on to the executive council map
uh
again the 2010 map was already
gerrymandered and very clearly
gerrymandered um with the dragon
district
and yes this may look a little bit
better
but
in a partisan a partisan
st
in a partisan sense it is even worse
than the the old map
it moves
4.2 percent more democrats into district
2 thus packing democrats and then uh
which leads to
district 4 becoming about one percent
more republican district five becoming
1.6 percent more republican um
and district 1 becoming 4.2 percent more
republican so
it's very clear to me
what was being done in these maps
instead of district 2 kind of being a
keen conquered dover district they
made it a keen concord
and then like hanover and up into
northern grafton to grab democrats up
there rather than going all the way
across the state um
it may look better but it's definitely
not better it breaks up nine of the ten
counties when it really doesn't need to
at all um
you know
if we had criteria we could better
define a better map but since we don't
have any criteria
people can say that you know this is the
best that we could do but it's clearly
not
um
i hope that you will uh amend both of
these
uh bills
with uh
maps that are
fair in that
they are more competitive
more compact
keep more communities of interest
together
and i hope that you will look at the the
mapathon proposals
and i would be
happy to you know help out in any way
that i can including answering any
questions you have now
all right thank you um mr andrews why
don't you just go through the handout
real quickly with us because i was
bouncing around as you were you were
testifying um and i believe this has
been online now in part
or in whole for a few days but online
for a little bit
um
you go through in the first page and
talk about the document and a little bit
of the history um and for members who
might be watching i'm sort of flying
through this because mr andrews and this
committee are familiar with each other
from before in the mapathon work so
um i'm doing this just so when we break
here people have looked at it so we know
what we have
um you also have provided a glossary of
terms
you have listed in the communities of
interest definitions
that you had were those the primary uh
ones that you use it doesn't appear to
be all of them but you you listed a few
if you could just uh clarify that
because you talked about the gross
number that you began with
yeah yeah we started out with i believe
it was 63 yeah on a list of everyone and
uh we kind of willed down to
five um
i don't believe there are five listed in
your definition what were the five
um they were
high school districts shared water
systems shared uh police and fire
in addition to hospitals
and um
we
there was a number of different
communities of interest that people
talked about with concern to um
like pfas and kind of general um
health and community well-being issues
uh drug use those kind of things that we
kind of put together and used i forget
the exact um
the yeah the public health um
metric that is released by the um
by the census bureau has a chart of um
the general
so high schools water districts shared
police and fire hospitals and public
health yep
okay
um
yeah and we we included um
i'm asking mr andrews as chair of the
committee for the benefit of the the the
committee looking at this because the
five communities of interest that he
mentioned were primary are do not appear
to be listed anywhere in this document
so i am asking him what they are he
could only remember four
olivia zink clarified that public health
was the fifth is that correct yes thank
you okay then you had some you have some
conclusions on the executive council
proposals and then you have
um three maps
on
i guess page five
and you talk about the minority majority
and mapathon what is the minority and
the majority proposal what does that
mean
um the
majority proposal is the current um
map that's in the in the bill that
passed the the senate um the minority
proposal was proposed
um in the senate in the senate okay so
that was a senate um bill
proposed okay great thank you for that
clarification
um
and then you have on the next page six
communities of interest which are
labeled
and then i believe the next page you've
clearly labeled the 2010
current map with of course the district
2 which we heard a lot about for 10
years
and then the next page
we have again this is what you're
referring to as
the majority
proposal
um
currently that we currently have before
us correct okay and then the minority
proposal was that another one brought in
front of the senate yep that's that's
the same map okay
and then that you have your mapathon
proposal
all right and then you wrap up with some
some comments great i just wanted to go
through that to make sure i understood
what i was looking at questions from the
committee for mr andrews
representative weber
thank you and thank you madam chair for
having us go through that because
it allows me to look at the actual
picture
of the 2010 executive council maps and
we all heard a lot about the dragon
district and those of us who were there
which is just me
the last time we did this
uh certainly yelled about that a great
deal at that time
but
what is bewildering me and what i'd like
you to comment on is that
uh not only the sponsor of the current
map but but you as well said that
this map
looks better
than
what we have now and to my eye
yes there is one peculiar district here
and here we have
three
exceedingly peculiar districts
so
in what way does this look better than
what we have now can i interject it
looks fairer um represent why don't you
go ahead and answer the question um yeah
so madam chair i really object to that
i'm
um
to um
answer that
one way that is actually generally
accepted in um
in
courts and other uh ways in in
redistricting is whether a district is
visually compact um
and i would agree that you know
definitely two and five in in this newly
proposed map are not
visually compact um you could argue that
district one is kind of um
but generally if you if you look at a
map and you say you know
whether it it
looks compact or not is um
i i would i would argue that you're
you're correct in that this one does
look look funky you have the kind of
tendrils that reach out and grab you
know peterborough and concord and then
up into grafton but um
the old map was very well defined as you
know the dragon district and it was you
know well known in that regard so it it
kind of uh
jumps out as being the you know the
example of gerrymandering in the last 10
years and thus um
that's why i i clarified that that was
you know looked worse
probably follow up
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my follow-up um
and and
now stepping away from the shapes and
considering what is
uh underlying the maps
would you agree with me that
what we have done in changing from the
old map to the new map
is that
we have significantly
uh
disadvantaged pretty much everything
north have conquered in terms of
having their own
having having a representative who both
lives in
in the heart of their district
and
having a district that is
uh
that has a completely
diffused population
a district composed of small towns small
cities and and even smaller towns
rather than being
connected to significant population
centers
which share even less
with the very rural districts yeah i
think that especially with the executive
council map you can think of it as um
almost regionally um
for instance like when i would would
draw executive council maps i would i
would think
you know all right five districts or
what kind of five regions of new
hampshire are there you know north of
concord uh keene
um you know
nashua manchester uh seacoast those are
kind of the five that i you know think
about in my in my head um and so that's
what how i would kind of draw it out
because i would think you know
a lot of the towns
north of concord have a lot much more in
common with each other than do towns
kind of south of new hampshire so um
yeah i agree that it
will definitely
it could
lead to less kind of
representation in in the north country
you know if you get a um
a rep uh
executive councilor out of dover and you
get one out of keene um
the north country it it's gonna be both
difficult for them to travel up there
and also
for them to have a kind of sense of
community and
really know what the residents of those
districts really want from their
counselor
thank you
further questions
i'm not seeing any thank you mr andrews
for being here again and and staying
with this project
um i would like to point out
sorry oh did you have a question i'm
sorry i missed it did he go through this
one yeah
yeah oh
sorry asleep in the switch okay thank
you okay
um
i don't have anybody else i don't have
any other pink cards before i close the
public hearing you all have received the
email
um from the aclu in regards
to
um
the
survey or analysis that they had done
i'm trying to download the link on my
phone
but you have the email with the link
presented in it
and ms inc was very helpful and provided
me with the information on when things
passed sb241
passed with the amendment
to create the bill we considered today
on march 24th out of the senate and sb
240 passed out of the senate on
february 16th
so with that this committee is going to
recess
we will be back here at one o'clock to
open executive session on these bills
thank you
all right good afternoon everybody it is
a few minutes after one o'clock we had
some technical difficulties that look
like they've been resolved we are live
streaming and being recorded now
um as i announced before we broke about
an hour and 20 minutes ago we are going
to have an executive session on the
bills we just heard the notice in the
calendar was appropriate
and we're going to go forward this
afternoon with sb 240 and sb 241
so with that i'm going to ask if there's
a motion on sb 240 representative
mcguire
thank you madam chair i move out to pass
is there a second to that motion
second
representative lynn seconds it
representative mcguire would you like to
speak to your motion yes madam chair
senate bill 240 is the state senate
districts as devised by the state senate
they meet all legal and constitutional
requirements
the districts are contiguous the
populations are
equal within appropriate limits and
therefore
i believe that that since we've verified
that they meet all requirements we
should support our colleagues in the
senate and vote for it
thank you representative mcguire further
discussion on the motion
representative weber
thank you madam chair
while i agree with my colleagues that we
should be very deferential to the wishes
of the senate
in
dealing just as we hope that they are
deferential to us in the
redistricting of the house
i have to point out that the map that we
have been sent has significant defects
in it
and one of the things that we heard
again and again when we had joint
hearings on other issues but
it can't be any different for the senate
districts is that our constituents
wanted districts that were compact and
competitive
and this map
provides neither we have
a number of districts first of all that
have been
the the partisan divide in the districts
has has increased enormously so
uh 15 of the
districts are demonstrably now more
republican leaning and
the democratic districts have been
packed so that their partisan lien is
far far greater than that of the
republican districts
so that concerns me for for item number
one
item number two which is that um
communities of interest have been
unnecessarily split in forming these
maps you have the most obvious issue is
in district nine which now stretches
from the connecticut river
some 70 miles some of which are
not
really following the way the roads go
uh all the way over to the outskirts of
manchester uh there are no interests in
common in that district and
uh speaking from the cheshire county
perspective the cheshire county part of
that map is significantly disadvantaged
by
being outweighed by the population being
on the other side of it
district 10 which used to be entirely in
cheshire county which made a great deal
of sense
now includes a couple of hillsborough
county towns whereas cheshire county
which is a small county
has been added to parts of four
different senatorial districts
we have
with respect to the cities
nashua has been split up and
nashua this remains split up but some of
some of the district 12 goes all the way
to rindge and cheshire county
manchester has been split up between
three different senatorial districts
and ward one has been connected
to candia goffstown hooksett and raymond
again
ignoring communities of interest
and so
i am concerned that this map has uh
really
been drawn to preserve the interests of
incumbents to the detriment of creating
competitive
districts and so that's my concern about
it and why i won't be voting for it
thank you
thank you further comments
representative lane
thank you madam chair
while i agree
with the representative um mcguire that
meets the legal requirements i think we
should strive for more than the bare
legal requirements
we represent all of our constituents not
just those that are of our party and we
owe them a duty to give them the best
maps possible and i do not think that
the maps that were proposed and passed
in the senate are those maps
and i would like to say that if we're
truly concerned about election integrity
the way we talk about and the election
law committee
then we need to focus more on than just
on the security of elections but we also
need to let voters know
that they are going to go into the
ballot box
and at the vote sorry the voting booth
and have a real choice and that their
choice is going to matter and under
these maps for many people in new
hampshire that is not going to be the
case and i think we could do a better
job and i had hoped that we would have
done a better job
and for that reason
and others i will not be voting for this
map thank you
thank you for their comments
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll the motion on the floor
is otp sp2
thank you madam chairman
uh representative stephen smith
yes
representative carol mcguire yes
representative chaircott
yes
representative mcdonald votes yes
representative lynn
yes
representative barry
representative roulade
um
representative bergeron no
representative lane
no
representative piedra no
representative weber
representative wilhelm no
representative long
no
representative mcgee no
representative griffin
yes
the motion carries
sb240 will be reported to the house as
ought to pass the other bill before this
committee to consider today is sb
it is
open to motion representative bergeron
thank you madam chair
i would move to amend senate bill
241 with amendment number 2022
dash 1543 h and i request to speak to
that amendment is there a second
representative weber second set
representative bergeron
thank you madam chair
um
let me first anticipate probably one of
the first questions i will get after i
speak so i won't have to answer it later
and this was unexpected the map-a-thon
handout that
was distributed during the public
hearing relative to the executive
council map
references a minority proposal and
provides some data regarding that
minority proposal
that is the proposal that was submitted
by the minority in the senate and it is
the proposal that's before you today
with the amendment that i just cited
um i began
during the public hearing i think i only
asked one question and it was asked of
senator gray regarding this bill
why didn't they just keep the existing
districts the way they were because
the population fell well within the
acceptable range of deviation
and his answer was
given the public testimony we heard
and the shape of executive council
district 2
and he was very very jointly avoided
using the word gerrymandered district
but i'm going to use it but he said that
was the reason for trying to redraw the
map
unfortunately or
or not
the senate plan kind of hacked away
the western portion of district 1 south
of carroll and west of lincoln and move
that into district 2.
district 5 has kind of a funny shape
almost like an alligator taking us a
bite out of
proposed district 2 under senate bill
241 so now instead of having
one oddly shaped executive council
district we have three
the amendment that's before you
proposes that
district one would run south
i'm sorry geographically district one
would remain a large district that
encompasses the northern part of the
state it's not split in half
as proposed by senate bill 241
the districts that we're proposing in
the minority proposal try and keep
counties intact within the consular
districts as much as possible and in
district one it incorporates five entire
counties coast carroll grafton belknap
and sullivan
rather than a district that's proposed
that has seven different counties or
pieces of them in that district
district two which was terribly
gerrymandered currently and in the
proposed senate plan
would become a much more compact
district under the minority proposal it
would include merrimack and stafford
counties in the northwestern part of
rockingham county
district 3 remains similar to the
existing district but
places candy and hudson in the district
and moves dairy into district 4 to
balance some population shifts
district 4 becomes more compact the only
town in the proposed district that does
not share a border with manchester is
derry
and district 5 would now encompass the
entirety of cheshire county and the vast
majority of hillsborough county
including nashua that's the major
differences between what's being
proposed in this amendment and what's
before us in senate bill 241 and i would
appreciate your support for the
amendment
thank you representative bergeron
further
uh comments
on the amendment before us which is 2022
1543 representative mcgee yes thank you
madam chairman
uh i just noticed in looking at the map
mapathon breakdown that a another
comparison chart here
lists that
the high school sau splits
under the current senate proposal
come out to 17
saus that are split their districts are
split
and the mapathon version is is three
so it's an improvement there for
something that i know
folks were coming out uh to the hearings
and asking for that there be some regard
given for those so there's a preference
there
um
and also the county splits which we
discussed in earlier testimony
uh are about half so the senate proposal
has nine county splits and the mapathon
version uh has
five
just for your consideration
excuse me madam chair
representative mcguire
she's talking about the mapathon
proposal isn't this the senate minority
proposal or instead
that is correct yes and i i believe
that the uh amendment sponsor mentioned
that that they it was the same
thank you i wasn't aware of that if if i
may manage
if you can explain because it is
presented in the mapathon work as a
minority proposal
yes the uh the minority proposal uh is
not the mapathon proposal it's not but
it's analyzed in the mapathon report
thank you
further
comment on the amendment before the
committee which is 2022-1543
in regards to the executive council maps
i'm seeing none so i'm going to ask the
clerk to call the roll
thank you madam chairman
uh representative steven smith
no
representative mcguire no
representative turcotte no
representative mcdonald votes no
representative lynn no
representative barry no
representative roulard
representative
bergeron
yes
representative lane
representative piedra yes
representative weber
representative wilhelm yes
representative long yes
representative mcgee
yes
representative griffin no
seven to eight madam chairman
the amendment
fails
uh we have
sb 241
in front of us are there any further
amendments on sb241
representative bergeron did you want to
bring something forward
uh no madam chair thank you um sb 241 is
before us um i'm not seeing anybody
indicating they have an amendment does
anybody have a motion to make
representative turcotte thank you madam
chair i move sb 241 as amended by the
senate ought to pass
second
it's been seconded by representative lin
on the floor in front of the committee
for vote is sb 241
otp is there any
discussion on the motion representative
turca
thank you madam chair um sb 241 as
amended by the senate is uh updates the
executive council
counselor maps
based on the most current census data
it uh ends up with a deviation just
slightly higher than one percent
it removes the old district two which
there is much consternation over
and lastly it does meet all
constitutional and legal requirements
thank you madam chair
further discussion on the motion before
the floor which is otp
sb 241
i'm representative lane
well if nobody else is uh so
um
well i agree that it replaces the old
district number two which is a dragon or
a snake depending on how you want to
call it it actually is
ends up with a worse result and is is
more gerrymandered than the one that was
put forth in 2010 and adopted in 2011.
and not to sound like a broken record
but i will repeat what i said last time
that we should strive for more than the
bare legal requirements
we represent all our voters i represent
the republican voters in my district
even though i'm a democrat i still
represent them and vote for their best
interest
and i think that if you are concerned
about election integrity you want people
to have faith in our entire election
process and that includes the
redistricting process
and with this map and the other maps you
are discouraging people
in
lopsided districts to not participate in
the vote voting process
and i would suggest that that does more
harm to election integrity and some of
the security measures that we've been
putting forth in the election law
committee
thank you
thank you representative lane further
comment on the motion the motion on the
floor is otp sb 241
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the role thank you mayor and
chairman
representative stephen smith yes
representative mcguire
yes
representative turcotte
representative mcdonald votes yes
representative lynn yes
representative barry yes
representative roulard
representative bergeron no
representative lane
no
representative piedra no
representative weber
representative wilhelm no
representative long no representative
mcgee
no
representative griffin yes
eight to seven madam chairman
sb 241 will be reported as ought to pass
i understand the minority report would
be itl with the minority amendment
ought to mess with it
and that has been report will be
reported
um is there any further business in
regards to these items 240 and 241
all right um we will be having a meeting
next friday i haven't looked at my email
to see if lindsay where the email or
notice
uh status is but we will be having a
meeting next friday
to consider
a non-german amendment to sb 200 which
will be a vehicle used by this committee
to consider congressional district maps
so
um
madam chair
yes representative i we did we did
receive the notice and it said the
proposed amendment was on the website
has it actually been posted on the
website do you know i don't know i
haven't looked i'll look now though
um the actual amendment will be
um is supposed to be posted and the
amendment itself will be in the calendar
but as with all the other amendments
i've discussed that i want it on the
website so we'll see what we can get
done
all right with that thank you very much
everybody for coming today and we'll see
you next friday
keep a lookout on the notice to find out
what room we're in
you